what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay Jacob fall Jacob fall a member of
the Rob Corps named Jacob has been
asking for weeks and weeks and weeks and
weeks for me to make a video on who
would win the unstoppable Colossus or
world breaker horn now Jacob says World
War Hulk but I assume he's talking about
war breaker Hulk since that's the
version that we saw during World War II
yes this video is for you Jacob ask
enough and you shall receive in order to
be able to effectively answer this
question we need to really kind of run
over the powers of what these characters
are in their regular forms and then talk
about these more powerful versions of
their characters so as most people know
the Hulk is one of the strongest
characters in the Marvel Universe now
due to his exposure to gamma radiation
his cells have been altered in such a
way that allows him to become
increasingly stronger that angrier he
gets furthermore it has been established
that there is seemingly no upper limit
to how strong the Hulk can become and
just to give you an idea of how strong
the Hulk is he's held up a mountain
weighing 150 billion tons and secret
Wars issue number four from 1984 and in
the Planet Hulk storyline he's able to
prevent a planet from exploding by
holding its tectonic plates together now
throughout his 50-plus years of history
the Hulk has battled several of the
strongest characters in the Marvel
Universe and has emerged victorious in a
vast majority of these contests thanks
not only to his unparalleled strength
but to his elite level durability and
his regenerative healing factor as well
just to run through some examples of the
ridiculous durability of the Hulk he's
twice survived the blast of a gamma bomb
and Incredible Hulk number 144 and tales
to astonish number 62 he survived a
nuclear bomb explosion an Incredible
Hulk number 440 and has endured an
attack from the Human Torch
hitting him at full force with super
nova level powers and walked away
without a scratch in Fantastic Four
number 534 sorry - keep in mind when
Johnny Storm pushes his powers to the
absolute limit of super nova levels
that's enough power to destroy a planet
now there are also several moments where
Hulk's extremely potent healing factor
is put on display for example during an
encounter with a villain called vector
Hulk actually has all
skin and muscle tissue melted off of his
body and is able to regenerate all of it
in a matter of moments an Incredible
Hulk number 398 during the future
imperfect story written by Peter David
the Hulk battles an evil future version
of himself known as the maestro now
during the battle maestro manages to
break the Hulk's neck however not only
does the Hulk not die but he heals
completely within a few days so while
exactly how fast the Hulk can heal does
vary depending on who's writing the
story we can definitively say that the
Hulk is able to heal from almost any
physical injury incredibly fast now to
put this into perspective all these
abilities that we've seen here so far
are dwarfed by the power of world
breaker Hulk now world breaker Hulk was
basically a story that resulted from the
Incredible Hulk
being jettisoned into space by the
Illuminati Charles Xavier Rhee Richard's
Doctor Strange under the idea that the
Incredible Hulk was too unpredictable
the problem was the Incredible Hulk
crash landed on a planet that was
basically war-torn he managed to defeat
the existing king claim one of the
members of the guard for his queen and
try to start a family for himself the
problem is that the ship that he arrived
on was basically sabotaged it exploded
and it killed everything he knew and
loved as a result the Incredible Hulk as
mad as he had ever been came back to
earth and waged war against almost all
the superheroes now in this story he
took on some of the most powerful
characters to have ever existed Doctor
Strange with full power and channeling
the energies of gods was defeated by
world breaker Hulk Colossus in his metal
form had his arms broken by The
Incredible Hulk the only person who was
able to stop him was the Sentry and even
then all he did was just fight The
Incredible Hulk
until they both powered down and that
was about it it was not a definitive I
defeated the Incredible Hulk I'm the
last man standing now this is world
Waker Hulk at his absolute peak what I
want to do here is I want to switch over
to the juggernaut and the reason why is
because while unstoppable Colossus is
Colossus it's that character channeling
the power of the juggernaut now
juggernaut draws his power from an
object known as the Crimson gem of
cyttorak an artifact that mist owes
immense strength and durability on the
person who wields it by channeling the
energy of the demon city rock itself now
sit Iraq is one of the
oh gods he basically existed on earth
long before the dawn of humanity but due
to the idea that the Elder Gods are
basically being destroyed and chased off
by the original Elder God kind of a
weird story what ended up happening is
SID Iraq took off to a pocket dimension
the result is that sin Iraq is a being
of immense power incredible power if Sid
Iraq were to show up on earth with the
full capabilities on display almost none
of the superheroes would actually be
able to stand against him now as the
avatar of Sid Iraq juggernaut possesses
superhuman strength to the extent but
he's been able to break mountains apart
like we saw in Hulk number 172 and lift
buildings out of the ground and used
them as weapons like he did an uncanny
x-men number 361 the juggernauts
durability allows him to withstand a
massive deal of physical damage and in
addition to this he's able to use the
gyms energy to create a force field that
renders him immune to basically any and
all physical attacks even characters as
strong as Thor as juggernauts force
field was able to shield him from Thor's
attacks in Thor number 429 were odin son
threw a hammer and it just bounced off
and nothing happened now in addition to
his ability to absorb damage juggernauts
able to survive without air food or
water and does not suffer physical
fatigue for this reason once juggernaut
begins moving it is physically
impossible to stop him furthermore
juggernaut has an almost instantaneous
healing factor for any damage that he
does take and so with that in mind the
unstoppable Colossus is a byproduct of a
story that happened in Marvel called
fear itself now this story largely
centered around the Asgardians in the
sense that it was the reveal that Odin
had a brother named Cole bore son but
the Kolbe or son had seen himself as the
rightful ruler of Asgard the result is
that Cole calling himself the serpent
intended to basically create all these
different hammers fashioned an army for
himself and invade Asgard the problem
with this came in the form of juggernaut
because of the fact that Cain Marko
donned his powers directly from Sid Iraq
when Cain Marko accepted the hammer he
ultimately became the avatar for a new
God as a result of this Colossus Illyana
Rasputin and a couple others traveled to
the Crimson dimension to meet with Sid
Iraq inform him of what was going on and
in turn asked that a new avatar be
chosen so that somebody could stand
against juggernaut the result of this is
Sidda rack chose colossus as his new
avatar and in return colossus became the
unstoppable colossus now with the powers
of the juggernaut he has everything that
we've listed so far with his abilities
pushed to the absolute extreme so he's
far stronger than he ever was before
far faster than he ever was before once
he starts moving he cannot be stopped
these are the kind of things that we see
with his character and just how capable
he is so to answer the question of Jacob
who would win wrote breaker Hulk were
unstoppable juggernaut I'm gonna give it
to unstoppable juggernaut and here's the
reason why
The Incredible Hulk has fought
juggernaut on two occasions that I'm
aware of
the first was an Incredible Hulk number
402 in 1993 and in this story juggernaut
had actually just taken the Hulk by
surprise but there's been a litany of
instances where the Incredible Hulk is
taken by surprise from an enemy and
ultimately comes out on top in this
instance the juggernaut beat him but an
Incredible Hulk issue number 457 The
Incredible Hulk beat the juggernaut and
actually stopped him while he was moving
however this was not just the Incredible
Hulk
this was the Incredible Hulk whose
powers were augmented by the villain
apocalypse now in the world war hulk
storyline
hulk ended up fighting against
juggernaut however when juggernaut came
running at him the Incredible Hulk
just uses momentum and threw him out of
the way we did not actually see a direct
fistfight between the two of them so we
can't really gauge that and use that as
a real explanation of if the two of them
ever went toe-to-toe but we did end up
seeing the Incredible Hulk break the
arms of Colossus in his metal form
however because the Incredible Hulk
under normal circumstances in his normal
form faced off against juggernaut and
lost in issue number 402 there's no
reason to believe that if he was able to
defeat him in World War Hulk that he
actually would have gone through and
fought him in the first place so the
indication here is that instead of going
to toe to toe with juggernaut he just
kind of used the momentum and threw him
out of the way if the Incredible Hulk in
World War Hulk had no problem with
decimating Reed Richards iron man
century Black Bolt
all these seven superheroes then why
would he basically avoid a fight with
the juggernaut why would he just use a
juggernaut momentum and just send him
flying in a different direction so I
would ultimately give this to
unstoppable Colossus to me unstoppable
Colossus is channeling the power of a
god from another dimension and the upper
limits of
God's power are never known they've
never really been seen before conversely
the Incredible Hulk strength has no
upper limit but that's all the
Incredible Hulk has is increased
strength unstoppable Colossus has magic
he's got unlimited levels of strength
he's got unlimited levels of durability
he's got unlimited levels of speed and
an unlimited regenerative healing factor
so I know this is gonna be debated I
know people are just gonna be like boo
hiss The Incredible Hulk would win I
know people are gonna be really really
upset so let me know down in the
comments section who you think would
take this cuz again my vote goes to
unstoppable Colossus but I know it's
gonna be a pretty debated topic so let
me know who you guys think would come
out on top here do you think that row
breaker Hawk would win or do you think
unstoppable Colossus would win but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys have the sub button
to become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]